[Music]
hi everyone salcon here
biology is the study of living systems
and you can look all around you and even
it yourself to recognize that living
systems and biology and nature is
fundamentally creative and for us to
understand it we have to be even more
creative
but don't take my word for it i'm going
to introduce you to some of my close
friends who can even better draw this
link between biology and creativity
creativity is super important in biology
because it's hugely important in the
process of evolution evolution often
takes a winding path to get to what we
see now
and we want to follow this path in an
attempt to understand it sometimes we've
got to be as resourceful and clever as
evolution has been that requires
creativity in how we solve problems and
even creativity in the questions we ask
creativity is so important for anybody
who is thinking about who is studying
biology because the question we're
trying to understand is not just
take in all the information that we know
about biology
we want people to imagine what biology
what the natural world what the physical
world what our you know
what our bodies can actually do what our
brains can do and to be able to do that
you need to
think out of the box you need to think
about things that haven't been thought
about before and that is why biology
that is why uh creativity is so critical
for anybody studying biology creativity
isn't exclusive just to the arts but it
also spans into science and technology
and engineering and mathematics
creativity and science comes down to
thinking about a problem or situation
and how best to approach that problem or
situation from multiple angles
so when you approach a problem in the
real world it won't be multiple choice
like you may have at school it actually
would be something that requires you to
think about that particular situation
and apply other things you've learned
about it to be creative and to come up
with
answers that may not have been familiar
to you before
one question that people ask me is how
do i apply creativity
to the presentations that i give and my
secret sauce
is to come up with a visual image that
anybody i don't care for the adult
whether you're a fifth grader or second
grader that you can grasp that concept
and here's my favorite one so every
single time you move your body there's a
whole bunch of neural chemicals that are
released in your brain
and you've heard of these neurochemicals
dopamine noradrenaline
serotonin and so that's the fact but the
image that i give is that every single
time you move your body it's like giving
your brain a wonderful bubble bath of
neural chemicals that enrich your brain
that change that neurochemical milieu
and that is the image that everybody
that comes to my talks leaves with and
inspires them a little bit to move their
body more so can you come up with that
image that that playful fun but but
factually accurate image that conveys
your message that will be your secret
sauce too
have you heard that the bees
aren't doing great
well i've been studying that and trying
to understand how their complex health
issues
connect to a curious little parasite
that's in nearly every honeybee colony
worldwide it's called varroa destructor
by the way now
before i started this study we thought
that it was an open and shut case that
the parasite was sucking out the bee's
blood sort of like a tick on a puppy but
i thought something more strange might
be going on the the damage that it
caused just didn't seem like the damage
that would be caused by blood removal
the feeding process is super difficult
to see though so
i had this idea
i i fed different color glowing food to
the bees in their pollen and their sugar
water to color their organs specific
colors then when the parasite fed on the
bees
i could tell which organ it was eating
based on which color was in its
digestive system and it turns out that
they were eating the bee's liver by the
way
which is pretty weird um but
this kind of work is actually pretty fun
and it was definitely a place where
creativity was rewarded in biology
[Music]
some of the world's greatest discoveries
have been reached by applying creative
thinking to scientific questions
here's a good example i have been super
inspired by the creativity of the geiger
marsden gold foil experiments since i
was in high school they they have helped
us understand the structure of an atom
and atoms make up pretty much everything
we can interact with biological or
otherwise like
you can't see an atom so
you've got to get creative to figure out
how its pieces are all laid out
we used to think that its positive
charge was pretty evenly spread out
but this research team
fired a beam of positively charged
particles at gold atoms and found that a
bunch of them bounced off while even
more of them passed straight through
and this suggested that the the positive
charge in the atom was concentrated in a
small part because some of the positive
particles were repelled like the two
positive poles of like two separate
magnets but much of the rest of the atom
must be empty space because a bunch of
the particles pass right through because
of this absolutely genius way of
visualizing what we can't see we now
know the structure of the stuff that
makes up the observable universe
and
because of this pioneering research
we've got everything from nuclear power
to mri machines even the life-saving
technology that's inside of the smoke
detectors in your home
[Music]
so the first step to these discoveries
is always the same figure out your
question
maybe you want to know where fireflies
go during the day or or how mosquitoes
find people to bite and then you should
create a hypothesis
maybe mosquitoes find people by
following the smell of sweat and their
breath
then consider what must be true for your
hypothesis to be true you you might not
be able to test a mosquito's smell
receptors directly but if your
hypothesis is true people who are
exercising and thus exhaling a lot and
producing more sweat should attract more
mosquitoes
actually i probably shouldn't encourage
you to experiment on humans
that's um
why don't you uh maybe try the firefly
question instead
young people can get creative in science
by using not just science but other
things that they're learning from their
life and connecting it to science or
connecting science to other things in
their life such as
art and other things that are outside of
the dish of the traditional stem fields
for example when you're looking at or
wondering about how something works like
an mrna vaccine or how the organ systems
work you can use other aspects of your
life and learn to make or draw analogies
between different systems that's a
really important aspect of being
creative and using critical thinking
because a lot of systems are similar to
other systems even though they use
different names or look very different
and you can expand on your knowledge on
something by being creative or using
other things outside of science to draw
connections between different fields and
different things